so you just started Middle Earth shadow
of Mordor and you're thinking I'm a
badass Ranger with freaky Wraith
abilities
all y'all orcs are about to feel the
sting of my blades and then die horribly
well think again my Fulani
rush into battle and shadow of Mordor
and you'll see a whole lot of this
so yeah shadow of Mordor can be pretty
tough especially in the first few hours
and though you respawn quickly and even
gain an XP boost for dying death comes
at a price
see those orcs moving up the chain of
command especially the one that killed
you they're all getting tougher meaner
and more man hungry but if you play
smart the tide of battle will slowly
shift your way here are a few tips to
make your first few hours in shadow of
Mordor go a little smoother tip 1 don't
play this like you're Ezio Auditore
diferente sure tallien may move with the
grace of an assassin but this is no
Assassin's Creed game combat here is
definitely more challenging so don't try
to take on the hordes and expect to
survive these orcs may be dumb but their
sheer numbers can easily overwhelm you
so don't be afraid to scurry away and
come back around to murder orcs another
time this leads to our second tip stalk
your prey you'll soon notice that
picking fights tends to attract other
orcs so what may start out as a
manageable battle between you and a few
rogues can quickly escalate into a multi
captain mosh pits all means
by elbows and Doc Martens you're dealing
with orc steel and explosive arrows
tallien is a stealthy dude so use his
skills to isolate your foes identify
captains in each area using your Wraith
Oh vision stop them from up high and
don't engage until they've moved to a
relatively isolated position orcs don't
tend to look up very much so sticking to
the high ground and following you
captain shouldn't be a problem oh and
while you're at it thin out any
companions a captain may have with some
well-placed headshots captain's won't be
as much of a hassle when they're forced
to take you on one on one
our third big tip is multifaceted choose
your upgrades wisely Italians upgrade
tree has some sweet moves available for
unlocking as you progress through the
game but some are more handy than others
especially if you want to give yourself
an edge in combat in the first tier of
upgrades choose Rafe stun and impact
Wraith stun is a move you should be
busting out regularly as it stuns your
target for a few precious seconds impact
does something similar
staggering or stunning any orc you
manage to parry and trust us any skill
that disables your enemies mid fight is
a good skill the second tier has some
great abilities as well but you'll only
unlock these by completing story quests
I don't want to get too spoilery here
but if you want to use the excellent
shadow strike and Wraith flash make room
on your dance card for deagle
I mean Smeagol wait which one is he
going by these days oh oh oh
shadow strike allows you to traverse
long distances quickly which is handy
for sneaking around while Wraith flash
allows you to do an area of effect blast
in the heat of battle the third tier of
abilities is where you'll get the very
handy vault stun which stuns any enemy
you jump over this is an awesome ability
to have during battle so the quicker you
get this the better
also in Tier three is the race finisher
not only does this allow you to quickly
string along kills while in combat its
head popping finale also terrifies
nearby orcs giving you some much-needed
breathing room in the
of battle once you get to tier 3 you'll
be a much fiercer and deadlier force to
be reckoned with more like the Ranger
you hope you'd be then the Ranger you
actually work will you now be able to
take on all of mothballs challenges on
your own well maybe not but the sharp
rise in decapitated orc heads is a sign
you're on the right path
you